hi there steve coffin uh
how is everyone today i'm going to talk
about
motivation and lazy language learning
and
lazy language learners
and the example of a lazy language
learner is me
and what i mean by that is that
i don't like doing anything that feels
like work
when i learn languages
the only time that i really worked at my
language learning was when i was
learning chinese
back in 1968 and there was a good reason
because i was paid by my employer the
canadian government trade commissioner
service to learn chinese so i worked at
it six seven hours a day i was paid a
salary so i did everything i sat in
class for three hours a day i answered
questions i wrote i did all these things
but in all the languages that i have
learned on my own since then and there's
a total of 12.
i don't do those things i do things that
i find interesting and things that i
enjoy doing
so
i like to buy books on language learning
because i'm always interested in content
in reading i want to be exposed to the
language
but all these books you know and here's
one for example for check
is just full of exercises
exercises you know fill in the blanks
and the sentences and and uh connect
this to that and
you know explain why in the story uh
so and so uh
visited her cousin and
i never never do those i hate doing them
and i don't do them
because i'm too lazy
i don't do stacks of
flash cards i
flash card in a very haphazard way when
i feel like doing it
i might typically go through a list of
words before i
before i read a lesson at link
going through the the words that i have
already
you know started to learn my yellow
saved links
and i go through them in flashcards but
when i do flashcards i don't
try and scratch my head to guess at the
meaning of something i put
everything on the front side of the
flashcard
the you know the word in the foreign
language in check
uh the what we call the hint which is
the suggested meaning and the captured
phrase i see them in uh you know on the
face of the flash card and i'll just go
through them very quickly it's just
exposure i don't try to force myself to
think
um
you know i don't like i do review
grammar but again not with the objective
that i'm going to learn it it's just
exposure just like the flashcard is
exposure but most of my time i spend
doing interesting things
um so yeah i'm lazy i won't go to class
um what else don't i like to do
what else is there answer questions
um
yeah because i know like also
so i like to read things of interest but
i will also review beginner material and
this is another thing when i start into
my beginner books teach yourself or
whatever it might be or beginner lessons
at link i know that i'll be back at
those in you know in a month in three
months in six months and it'll be easier
every time so i'm not
concerned about mastering anything i
don't try to memorize tables i'm too
lazy to try to memorize tables
i don't read out loud i don't
learn the international phonetic
alphabet i i don't never use it
i just listen
uh and i at first the car the
pronunciation is difficult and there's
things that i miss at first and then i
get later on there's always this idea
that we aren't going to notice things
the first time around when we'll notice
them later on so i'm quite comfortable
to just let it go
i jump around
from more difficult to less difficult
different material
and i just i just do whatever the spirit
sort of
wherever the spirit moves me that's
where i go um
so in that sense i'm a lazy
language learner i'm not a disciplined
language learner i won't do these i
don't do shadowing for example i won't
go out there and deliberately learn 100
phrases or 300 sentences or or whatever
it is
um
i like to review phrases specifically
you know patterns of different or
examples of different patterns in the
language all of that is is just a
process of of exposure
so that eventually my brain is going to
start to pick up on these things
but i don't do it with any system or or
with any discipline because i'm
essentially lazy
it doesn't matter if you're lazy you
know i take the path of least resistance
and it doesn't matter because
i get back to the
the three
keys to language learning success
motivation
time on task or time with the language
specifically and developing the ability
to notice
so
i'm motivated to learn
like i was at my uh
today
uh oh tomorrow's my birthday by the way
anyway today i played the old-timers
hockey
then i went to a korean-run japanese
restaurant
spoke a little bit of korean with this
waitress there
and she said she had a friend over
they're both 25 and the friend was here
in vancouver to learn english and she
was very homesick and depressed and
ended up going home and she didn't like
it here and i said well why why did she
even come then is she not interested in
learning like we don't know she's not
very interested i mean if you're not
interested you're not going to learn
so the fundamental thing is to be
interested
motivated interested like it want to do
it
that's 70 of it if you've got that the
details of what you do are less
important the second thing is not only
am i motivated but i spend a lot of time
at it
mostly it's listening like today i did
uh
i think i did um the latest uh you know
episode from yakuto video on tech radio
went through it on link saving all the
words and phrases which then i can read
later on on my ipad
while driving to hockey i listen to some
korean because i found a
korean book i like to buy books i bought
this in beijing quite a few years ago
never got around to looking at it but
it's not bad so i was listening to this
in the car
korea
uh then as i say i went to lunch chatted
with the korean waitress there for a
while in fact that was the motivation i
wanted to get my korean up to her i
could perhaps chat her up a little bit
did this book
then i went to the office worked a bit
then i came home
and
i like to work out the day i play my
hockey you know get rid of the lactic
acid in your legs kind of thing so i get
on my stepper
and i read
that check text that i had uh gone
through and saved all the links from
on the computer in the morning did that
for 20 minutes and then i lifted some
weights for another 20 minutes while
listening to some more check so that's
how i get in my language
uh so i spend the time
and the other thing is
because i'm taking the initiative in all
of this i i'm looking for things that
help me notice so i do review grammar i
do go back to simple uh simple dialogues
uh i'm always trying to pay attention
when i listen and read so i start to
notice the different uh
you know declensions and cases in czech
and all this kind of stuff
so motivation
time with the language
and
learning to notice you do those things
you can be a lazy a lazy language
learner but you have to be
motivated and if we talk about
motivation
i think a lot of the things that
language learners are asked to do forced
to do
the things that are pushed at them
uh like you know trying to learn the
declension tables learn the conjugation
tables
answering these questions explain this
in the text why multiple choice
i think that's demotivating because as i
said in a recent
video in terms of motivation for a
worker
they found that rather than monetary uh
reward
independence
a sense of mastery
and a sense of purpose are extremely
motivating so if a learner is allowed to
choose the language choose what to learn
choose when to learn that's independence
if they have this sense that they're
gradually gaining more and more mastery
over the language
that's more important than responding to
a specific question
from a teacher
so mastery and then purpose
that korean girl who came to vancouver
she didn't know why she came she wasn't
but as 25 i'm sure her parents weren't
paying for she paid her own way
presumably to come here to study english
she's not interested she goes home there
has to be a sense of purpose
so
you have those things that motivate you
you spend the time with the language and
you work on that developing that
alertness attentiveness that ability to
notice how the language works that's all
you need you can be a lazy language
learner
and you can still succeed
thank you for listening bye for now